When I tell people that I'm on the debate team, I generally get one of two responses.
The first being, I could never do that.
The second, wow, people have always told me I would be great at debate. I love to argue.
Well, both of these responses illustrate a real problem with how we view debate today.
Debate is seen as a fight.
If an argument is seen as a fight, then the winner is the person who can talk the loudest,
who looks the prettiest on stage, or who can garner the most support.
Yeah, debate is so much more than that.
It's about who is the best speaker and who can illustrate their points the strongest.
Now, this isn't all just a shameless plug to try and get you to join the debate team.
But you should join.
This is a shameless plug to get you to reevaluate the way you form an argument and an opinion,
because real debate needs facts, logic, reasoning, and refutation to hold up.
So, I'm going to tell you the story of the first time I remember losing a debate.
So, I was with my mom and my younger sister in the car, or my older sister in the car,
and we were driving home from school.
And I told them what I learned that day, that Mount Everest is the tallest mountain in the whole world.
My sister immediately shot me down.
She said, actually, Mauna Kea in Hawaii is way taller than that.
I started screaming at her.
I said, no, you're wrong.
A little spoiler alert, I was wrong.
So, actually, Mauna Kea is a mountain in Hawaii, but it's like a volcano.
And if you go below sea level, it's about a mile taller than Everest.
I didn't know that at the time.
And I had learned from my teacher that Mount Everest was the tallest, so I believed it.
And I fought to defend that point, just with words.
My sister would win, but in a fight.
But I fought to get that point together, even though I didn't have all the information.